outside military barracks in downtown
wagodugu an eerie calm broken only by
the sound of gunfire
al jazeera went inside the camps and
spoke to the soldiers they made a series
of demands but did not call for the
dismissal of burkina faso's president
rock
kabure adapted
foreign
has faced attacks by armed groups linked
to al-qaeda and isil in recent years
an estimated 2000 people have been
killed and a further 1.5 million have
been displaced while the government has
resorted to arming civilians to fight
off armed groups many in the armed
forces see this as a mistake they say
they should be given the means to fight
armed groups not civilians
we were just taken inside the cab as
mutineers pointed their guns at us
inside we saw mutineers with ski masks
firing their guns in the air demanding
to be heard the government says the
situation has returned to normal the
defense minister denies this was a coup
attempt saying president kabore is safe
and still in charge
i strongly deny first of all the head of
state has not been detained no
institution of the country has been
threatened so as i said these movements
are localized they are circumscribed and
we're following the evolution of those
movements
on saturday security forces fought with
anti-government protesters who blamed
the leadership for failing to stop the
attack by armed groups
negotiations are underway between the
president and the soldiers who staged
the mutiny but trust is hard to come by
caught in the middle of the people of
burkina faso
in a country that appears to be
spiraling
out of control henry wilkins al jazeera
wagadugu